c'est vers audonienne ville fantôme et
avenue déserté c'est la ville que les
russes essaient de conquérir avant de
lancer leur grande offensive vers l'est
les civils y sont en grand danger
pourtant dans cet abri ils sont encore
nombreux
ces longs couloirs date de l'époque
soviétique
plusieurs pièces sous terre et des
visages fermés
ces femmes et ces enfants vivent ici
depuis un mois ces familles explique ne
pas vouloir évacuer car elles craignent
de partir sans argent
depuis le 24 février on a plus de
retraite et plus de salaire personne n'a
d'argent au moins ici on a un peu des
d'humanitaires et aussi celle de l'armée
un nourrisson endormi et dans ce bon
coeur l'électricité et la télévision
[Musique]
pas d'eau courante
rudimentaire mais suffisant pour rester
au début on sera aidé par les
volontaires si on évacue mais après une
semaine il faudra payer un loyer et
comme on n'a aucune économie moi ma mère
ma soeur on ne peut pas louer un
appartement
cette femme est convaincue que cet abri
les protégera jusqu'au bout de tous les
bombardements pourtant à l'extérieur les
russes pilonnent la vie
nous avions rendez vous avec d'autres
civils dans un autre abri sous cet
immeuble mais cette frappe sème la
panique
ne rentrez pas ne rentrait pas
ces civils ne souhaite plus nous parler
il vaut mieux qu'on arrête on doit pas
attirer l'attention
cet homme accepte pourtant pendant une
accalmie de nous expliquer pourquoi lui
non plus ne veut pas partir
c'est difficile de quitter cet enfer on
ne sait pas quelle route est la moins
dangereuse de toutes façons et comment
se passerait ce voyage vers cramatte
orsc
malgré les bombardements intensifs
quelques centaines de civils sont
toujours assez vers audonienne sq selon
les autorités si ces civils restent dans
ces abris et ne fuit pas ils seront pris
dans une nasse meurtrière exactement
comme à mario vol d'où l'insistance des
autorités pour que tous ces gens partent
au plus vite